là
aucun public nous nous appartient le
public de ce soir est une découverte un
monde complexe qui tout d'un coup me
fait oublier pour peu que j'essaie de le
rencontrer physiquement il n'y a pas
d'amour inac des preuves d'amour avec
mon regard utilisés tels que l'écologie
me réclame de l'utiliser aucun se donne
la mission de me faire rencontrer les
gens qui sont en face de moi quelle que
soit la tête qu'ils me font merci et
tout d'un coup tout ce que j'avais prévu
dire s'échappe
parce que votre présence envahi mais
votre présence a aussi un avantage pour
moi c'est que pour peu que je décide de
m'y intéresser
je me redresse je passe tout d'un coup
du foetus à l'homme du vulgum pecus au
leader je vois trop souvent des managers
et beaucoup d'entre vous le seront
bientôt
victime de cette culture occidentale qui
nous a fait mettre le cerveau sur un
pinacle
je pense donc je suis entré en scène
chant prendre le moyen de regarder le
public
s'accrochant pupitre mon micro mes notes
bon alors mesdames et messieurs
aujourd'hui et c'est parti
cet orateur la haie formée à
l'européenne il est un peu l'autre
extrême de l'américain qui rentre en
scène vous souvenez tout le monde a vu
cette vidéo en hurlant sur scène je n'ai
même pas besoin de vous citer le nom de
ce dirigeant américain
l'entrée en scène doit se situer un peu
entre les deux mais ce que je veux
montrer simplement là c'est que la
première chose importante quand vous
entrez quelque part c'est de regarder
mais pas de regarder passivement de
missionner votre cerveau ou votre regard
plutôt d'aller chercher d'aller
rencontrer autrement dit vous devez
avoir quand vous entrez en scène une
décision de vous intéresser à l'autre et
comme le regard est condamné à la
relation singulière cher monsieur je
vais être obligé de procéder tout au
long de mon exposé par sondage aléatoire
si je sens d'aléatoire mans normalement
que je passe d'une dame qui se trouve
ici et qui me regardent comme ça un
monsieur qui se trouve là et qu'ils me
regardent au dessus de ses lunettes
mon cerveau fait immédiatement la
synthèse des deux et me calcule le mot
adapté aux deux dans le ton adapté aux
2es au rythme adapté aux deux parce que
quand vous parler en public vous gérez
trois lignes une ligne verbal le choix
des monts
une ligne tonale et une rythmique
je sais que les intellectuels dans cette
salle ne pense qu'au rythme à la ligne
verbal trouver les mots ce qui fait que
chaque fois on regarde la moquette et on
dit qu'est ce que je peux bien dire et
je trouve le mot en regardant le
plancher et je le place sur le public
je n'ai rien reçu j'impose je suis un
chef
si en revanche j'oublie tout simplement
par le choc de la rencontre je détruis
tout ce que j'avais préparé et tout d'un
coup vous sélectionnez en moi pour
atteindre le même objectif un chemin
différent de ce que j'avais préparé
c'est le seul moyen de faire du public
le co auteur du discours fini de
l'orateur parler en public ne consiste
pas à dire ce qu'on a prévu de dire mais
à aller au delà grâce au public autant
grâce à celui qui ne vous regarde pas ou
qui dort qui tout d'un coup réveille
votre cerveau sur une urgence damasio
neurobiologiste américain nous apprend
très bien que le cerveau fonctionne
toutes les décisions sont sur l'instinct
de survie
autrement dit celui qui s'endort pour
vous parler vous rend le service de vous
réveiller et tout d'un coup ça programme
dans votre corps et ça passe d'abord par
le corps ensuite ça arrive au cerveau ça
programme dans votre corps le molleton
l'ailé et le rythme adapté pour sauver
votre peau
la peau de votre dossier la peau de
votre entreprise
la peau de paris la peau de la france la
peau du monde tous en même temps dans
une seule verticalité et c'est ça que
vous avez à faire pas seulement sauver
votre peau
mais la peau du dossier voyez il ya une
différence énorme entre le leader et le
chef et je tiens à vous dire tout de
suite et chacun s'essaye à devenir
leader est aujourd'hui dans la crise
actuelle de nos entreprises la crise
économique la crise mondiale on a besoin
de leaders
c'est déjà bien d'avoir des chefs mais
les leaders sont différents en quelque
sorte le leader exposé le chef impose le
leader exposé et on le suit le chef
impose points il est évident que l'
envie de travailler n'est pas la même
pour le premier ou pour le second voyez
la notion d'imposition et d'expositions
à partir du moment où je vous regarde en
entrant je redresse mon dos sans y
penser
et tout d'un coup je passe dans un
système les regards que vous avez sur
moi le regard que j'ai sur vous créer un
système unique à cerveau multiples et
par ma bouche en ce moment parce que je
me nourris sur vous le feed
je vous donne le bac n'a versé pas
n'attendez pas quand vous parler en
public de donner le fid et de recevoir
le bac inversée tout en nous et élevé
dans l'idée inverse sein nourricier vous
au public et de la rencontre naîtra le
discours alors que l'on nous a mis dans
la tête
vous allez faire un beau discours bien
calculer l'envoyé et ça créera une belle
relation
je vous suggère d'inverser créer la
rencontre et elle appellera votre
discours
et comme nous sommes liés physiquement
par nos regards mois dans l'aléatoire et
vous sur moi et bien ceux qui parlent en
ce moment ce n'est pas moi c'est la
collectivité que nous représentons dans
la convention de la conférence il se
trouve que c'est le conférencier qui
parle mais en ce moment votre visage
mademoiselle ne peut pas ne pas
intervenir dans ce que mon cerveau est
en train de construire 10 à 100
milliards de neurones dans le cerveau et
votre visage et le fait que je l' ai vu
je ne sais pas comment mais tout d'un
coup et bien le texte qui suit derrière
est un texte qui résulte de notre
contact
par contre seulement vous êtes auteur de
mon texte de menton et de mon rythme en
autant que je le suis moi même
autrement dit un leader qui a la parole
du collectif
le chef tient sa parole donc le leader
exposé ce que le collectif a généré et
par conséquent comment le public peut-il
ne pas signer un texte dont il est
devenu le coauteur c'est pour ça qu'un
public suit le leader et travaille à
minima pour le chef parce que les
publics ce sens qu auteur du discours
fini avec l'orateur ça c'est le
leadership alors il existe un lieu dans
lequel on privilégie la rencontre et
ensuite on passe le texte repensez à ça
je suis sûr que la prochaine fois que
vous allez faire un exposé un public
tout le monde va essayer de regarder le
public avant de démarrer je vous le
souhaite privilégier la rencontre que
vous ayez toujours dans votre tête
avant d'entrer en scène et même en
entrant dans votre esprit mesdames et
messieurs j'ai peut-être des choses à
vous dire mais c'est pas le plus
important le plus important c'est qu'on
soit ensemble et c'est pas seulement
psychologique je construis avec mon
corps la relation à vos corps et donc
nous créons un système physiquement de
tuyauterie la rend à tracer de la
plomberie c'est une question de tuyaux
la colonne d'air et le regard avec ça
vous fait votre vie et les cerveaux
discutent entre eux on sait pas comment
mais ils discutent
moi je sais pas ce qui se passe quand on
se regarde tous les deux mais eux deux
ils savent il ya des centaines de
milliers d'actions dans le cerveau
humain
lisez damasio l'erreur de descartes qui
parle de l'intuition
si on ne parle pas sur l'intuition on
est foutu tout le plat la thèse ces deux
d'amener l'intuition à la pertinence si
je suis en regard sur vous si je suis
droit entre terre et ciel
je sais que mon cerveau et pertinents je
n'ai même plus le surveiller je sais
qu'il avance dans votre intérêt et dans
mon intérêt je parlais donc de ce lieu
de pure leadership et ce lieu devient
leadership nous apporte la réponse nous
dit pourquoi il faut faire de l'art
oratoire
chips et le théâtre en effet au théâtre
rien n'est imposé
et moi qui je suis passé par le théâtre
qui est mis en scène au capitole à
toulouse le paiera de nancy à droite et
à gauche
je suis fasciné par le théâtre parce que
les gens qui arrivent ne sont pas
obligés de venir
ils s'installent volontiers dans un
salle et au moment où ils s'installent
tout d'un coup au bout d'un certain
temps les conversations se font
et puis tout d'un coup noir salle on a
même la scène balance de lumière entre
la salle et la scène
la salle se retrouve dans le noir les
conversations commencent à s'éteindre
certaines durent encore mais on voit
plus son voisin donc on a plus tendance
à lui parler et puis tout à coup les
trois coups du brigadier tout le monde
se tait et là on attend le miracle
quelqu'un crierait au feu à ce moment là
il ya 100 morts
mais le public est là comme un banc de
poissons et dans un banc de poissons
tous les poissons sont différents chacun
a donc été respectée dans ce qu'il est
et tous les poissons en même temps si on
la regarde vers la scène dans le noir
face dans la fauteuil à la scène
combien de manager rêverait d'avoir en
arrivant sur le kick off annuel à public
préparé de telle façon et disponible je
suis sûr qu'un manager qui aurait ce
public là dans le monde de l'entreprise
il en est pas en scène il se barre
tellement la tente du public est forte
et une fois que les brigadiers l'
ouverture du rideau l'acteur n'est pas
encore entrée en scène et le public est
déjà prêt et enfin arrive le corps de
l'acteur incarnant le personnage est là
on a le théâtre mais vous voyez que le
théâtre par son architecture et s'irrite
met en place la rencontre à ce moment là
l'acteur peut rentrer ce qui est très
difficile dans nos entreprises très
difficiles en politique c'est que dans
le monde en dehors du théâtre
eh bien nous sommes au théâtre inversée
quand un manager rentrer en réunion il
ya la même lumière sur lui et sur ses
collaborateurs il apparaît posthume
différents il n'ya pas les 3 to y'a pas
de rampes ya rien
il est dans un désert les gens sont en
général en train de bavarder entre eux
gül moi je disais que tu fus dimanche au
japon boj vtt golf chez moi j'ai vu que
tu fais toi tu es maintenant tout le
monde bavarde comme ça et le manager est
là alors il y en a qui tape sur le vert
y en a d'autres qui dit
et puis voilà donc on sait pas très bien
comment faire et puis et puis le manager
on l'a pas préparé non plus parce que le
comédien a fait de la dramatique mais le
manager n'a pas fait d'art oratoire
donc il sait pas comment placer son
corps il sait pas commandé à un regard
place et un dos et servir une voix avec
la voile du palais place est ici pas
hélas le manager est en difficulté par
rapport à l'acteur parce
qu'effectivement rien n'est préparé on
est au théâtre à verser au théâtre
classique
acteurs rentrent le dernier et tout est
prêt dans l'entreprise et en politique
l'acteur rentrer le premier et quand ils
entrent tout de suite il se passe en
quelques secondes théâtre inverser ça
dure très longtemps ota c'est dur très
peu de temps en entreprise
le manager rentrer en scène ouvre les
paupières c'est l'ouverture du rideau
regarde son public même si un droit
équivalent du brigadier il sort le
premier saut il sort le premier sont
tout d'un coup le public ouvre les yeux
ce sont les projecteurs qui s'allument
sur lui ce sont les yeux des spectateurs
vos yeux sont des lumières et ses
lumières sont justement le projecteur
sur l'orateur et encore faut-il que
l'orateur ne méritent les yeux
s'allument
tout le monde regarde ce sont les
projecteurs théâtre inversés et c'est
dans l'ordre inverse
ensuite tout d'un coup sûr et en réunion
le manager a commencé à parler dès les
deux premiers mots la voix est tellement
belle musicale la voix c'est ce qui
porte les harmoniques
c'est donc ce qui porte le sens la
pensée humaine est complexe par
conséquent elles réclament un instrument
de transmission à sa hauteur de
complexité célèbre humaine c'est pas le
geste c'est la voix humaine qui porte
toute la complexité et la beauté du son
ayez un projet artistique quand vous
parlez un public un projet relationnel
le regard un projet musical la voix ayez
ces deux projets est le cerveau suivra
on met la charrue avant les boeufs on
met d'abord le cerveau et puis le camp
n'a qu'à se débrouiller derrière et bien
souvent en plus on oublie les bleus
c'est ça la catastrophe et beaucoup de
managers sont trop dans leur tête et pas
assez dans leur corps et puis quand les
projecteurs sont allumés et ça s'est
passé dans les premiers mots très très
court immédiatement tout d'un coup ayant
allumé les gens ce recul et tout d'un
coup on regarde ce manager qui n'est
plus tout à fait lui-même il incarne un
personnage et là on est passé de la
personne aux personnages et seul le
personnage a du leadership parce que
c'est un message
une personne n'est pas un message c'est
un ensemble de contradictions un
personnage est une forme pure qu'on
donne au théâtre et qui fait que tout
d'un coup dans le miroir du théâtre le
monde le parti d'humanité qui est dans
la salle se reconnaît les orateurs les
auteurs pardon de génie dessine des
personnages et propose un miroir à
l'humanité dans laquelle elle se
reconnaît et elle sort du théâtre plus
cultivé plus connaissant elle même sa
propre nature donc plus sage c'est le
rôle de la culture
c'est le rôle de l'art en général de
proposer un miroir aux hommes
ça c'est le théâtre est bien le théâtre
inversons le mécanisme du miroir et nous
aurons notre société et lorsque tout
d'un coup les yeux se sont allumés et
bien tout d'un coup relégué recul du
public qui s'étonne de voir ce
personnage plus grand que la personne
cicéron disait m le corps et la voix à
la hauteur de la dignité de la couse
mettre le corps et la voix à la hauteur
d'élite et de la course ça veut dire que
le corps et la voix sont essentielles à
la communication orale et ça veut dire
tout simplement que alors que les
comédiens dont on prépare vraiment le
terrain prennent des cours d'art
dramatique à prennent à incarner tout un
bandit en anglais avec leur corps
proposer un personnage de telle sorte
que quand ils sont en scène six dont
joints et bien joué ce n'est pas vous ne
voyez plus l'acteur vous voyez don juan
et vous y croyez c'était votre souhait
j'irai même plus loin sur la scène vous
n'avez pas donjon vous avez le
donjuanisme vu par molière
ça s'appelle un personnage parce que
dans la convention de l'oral ça passe
par le corps de la personne qui parle
on appelle ça un personnage en réalité
ce qui est sur scène c'est la vision que
molière avait du donjuanisme c'est ça
l'incarnation d'une idée un manager est
payé pour incarner son idée du
management de l'entreprise
je suis moi payer ici pour incarner
l'art oratoire
je ne suis pas payé puisque les ted sont
faites
avec générosité considérable des
intervenants bon mais c'est vrai ça
c'est mon vieux côtés de comédiens qui
ressort j'attends le cacher c'est une
évidence bon mais vous voyez que cette
notion du personnage là la construction
du personnage titre magnifique d'un book
and safety la construction du personnage
et mettre le corps et la voix à la
hauteur desdites et de la côte
vous incarnez un personnage et le
personnage est toujours plus grand que
la personne j'ose espérer mesdames et
messieurs que ce que je vous ai donné ce
soir est plus grand que ce que je suis
merci